hey let's go breasts buddies today we're
playing finger it's not actually about
fingering people all right well I hope
you enjoyed thank you for watching and
this thing great oh you didn't just come
for the thumbnail oh well let me play in
the game then this game is made by
Edmund McMillen I didn't know that I
recognized sound now uh you made meat
boy and binding of issac both awesome
games so this game must be awesome - yes
basic Bob just a quick disclaimer I have
no idea how to play this game I have no
idea what I'm doing I just know that day
one we have basic Babin boy do I like
fingering basic Bob do you like this bap
do you like when I paint I can't say it
it's disgusting this game is just shame
on you shame on your headman and that
other guy who made this basic Bob what
are you telling me I'm positive he
looked ugly well I'm positive they're
all looking ugly except of course double
beard double glasses Mac duck face you
over here Jesus Christ that's one sexy
son of a [ __ ] that one is definitely
100% angling all right now right so we
need to release the one that it looked
Emily well you are released
you have sideburns like an angel yeah
free to go
so I already understand what the game is
and that's awesome so I can use more
hints I'm positive he looked odd well
will mr. Bob they all agon bomb
Gaia's the [ __ ] butt on its face
isn't that odd enough that's odd
this guy's strange but maybe not on
what's the other hint
I'm positive he looked dark you can say
his black Bob you can say his black it's
okay all right well that settles the
court yeah free checkup sorry got a
little out of hand there we're fine
next day we happen I love this game all
right we have nearsightedness she tries
her best so do i so do I have you seen
me like squint in every episode ever
Am I I'm over it I'll just wear the
[ __ ] glasses he definitely did not
look like skin and bones so he was not
he's fat nice that's what you're saying
why is that guy crying poor soul your
leaves I'm so sorry we can't be in here
you need to be at YMCA you look like you
miss your brother you're the kind of
issues I'll keep you in for now man
there's so many so many possibilities to
finger people given in the chair are you
sure you did it yeah
man this is too easy I'm too good but yo
my god
we're a team we're a team we're to get
what we were doing so great you're
watching me play a game about a man he
has a face as a nose look at that that's
a silhouette of a face and try to hide
that [ __ ] Illuminati I pay attention
bigger party he's that racist I don't
like that's not good he definitely did
not look like a freak
does that guy look like a freak he has
the Jesus crown and he asked for help
and I think - he has some vampire -
bliss he might be half Smurf so I'm just
gonna go ahead and release him uh does
he not look like a freak I think anyone
with the [ __ ] Japanese butchered
James sub knife English and you're
afraid to cut that guy no not afraid
you're a freak
yeah that's that's my uncle actually
that's kind of like a pet let him go and
you have a moist I'm so sorry
don't flag the video no that was that it
okay well that's okay tell me bro us
which one you think I did you know we
all messed up in life Negative Nancy
she's always so negative
mmm that's probably cause she has
someone tenth only I've been negative
two negative one Teddy up top that was a
good joke it definitely did not look
like he was bawling that means it could
be either bald not wait not look like he
was bawling so
ever did it look like you had a lot of
hair alright well is this a trick
question
yeah give me a hit did not look dark
you're afraid I got mate yeah Fred I got
ya Freddy oh you're [ __ ] ugly-ass
[ __ ] you're free this render movie
procedure originally generated because
then I'm impressed
alright we got two options not balding
and not time get him in the chair finger
that base I love you
finger finger this is my new favorite
game I love it I love it I love it
Oh Tim dad oh he's my favorite
what time shall a new boyfriend material
don't tell Marcia
he's usually wrong about something is
that it is that clue for the next page
maybe I could be um I'm positive he look
not messy you have tied the knot that
confuses me he looks nice alright got it
late at night not messy he did not look
messy it did not look miss that guy
doesn't look messy scared search here
why are you so scared sad yeah breasts
feel free to help Jesus guys I'm trying
over here that guy looks messy and they
[ __ ] pimple over again I do clean
your [ __ ] face this is [ __ ] your
mouth your eye as a mouth alright you
made your messy go away your messy all
right your messy so that leads us to
number three and number six he asked for
help no I will get a hit he looked like
a no hair
sir Jim how do not put you in your chain
finger
you disappoint me Sergio you disappoint
me ha another Easter case settled by the
fingering man himself Peter back feel
free to put that on my grave soon I
would be very much appreciated so it
doesn't really matter what the Texas I I
thought for like a second that there's
like actual a note to self you may be
guilty don't say that you don't know me
how many days should be with you let's
do 10 days and that guy has a cross on
his face so why are we helping evil
Eddie and what did these people do to
evil Andy I bet they're stole his hat I
bet they did did not look poor alright
well let this is getting a little racist
and a little gentle and a little
prejudiced and I don't know if tumblr
can handle this but let's be honest that
guy looks like he's straight-up [ __ ]
pimping look at those sunglasses
those must be Prada I swear those are
Protestant that guy is wearing a [ __ ]
Sponge Bob as a hat is poor go away this
guy listens to me you remember my quote
don't be a salad be the best goddamn
broccoli you could ever be this guy
lives up to that and you're too Brown
that's a good thing
you look poor I'd say you look like a
trashy [ __ ] I'm so sorry you look poor
go away
you're on your own pot you're all pork
all right what's the other hand he
definitely did not look like my kind of
guy
well do you like broccoli like I don't
know what to tell you
is this your camera guy oh this good can
I don't know I think he look young all
right [ __ ] it and then and then I wish
it so wait I have a question this can i
unlock all the hint or like do I get
more points for using less hints
because I thought if I use less hints
that would give me more points that
would make sense
Edmund please like do I have to tell you
how to fix sorry I said that I think you
look I thought like last me I think he
looked bald oh that changes everything
it a work finger in you oh yeah buddy
it doesn't even look remorseful do you
have anything like to say to yourself
yeah broccoli [ __ ] I didn't think that
one was right how it was that it was
bald oh you were a wig that's clever
I take it all back take it all back
let's search for pepper yeah
oh my god pre-madonna pittypat yeah
damn it she borrowed it on a balloon Oh
Brendan can I seriously print it I can't
print it oh my god I got to pray that
right now
sentenced to 15 days of beatings well he
deserved it very nice music did you like
it it's printing
it's coming so here we go I'm gonna put
this on my chair because no one's ever
done that [ __ ] and I'm really XO there
you go that's pretty good ahh
so that was fingering I don't think
there's much why is he keep depending oh
great
this is great alright well that adds to
the mood check out this game I'll leave
a link to in the description I think it
was fun I enjoyed myself and thank you
for watching I hope you enjoyed as well
leave a like if you did I am I'm like
hey that's cool that's a face that's a
little creepy
I'll see you brothers in the next video
as always stay awesome press